ich habe es verstanden es geht hier
nicht um ein virus oder so es sterben
menschen an altersschwäche
weil sie vielleicht noch eine erkältung
dazu bekommen haben oder irgendwie so
und die sagen hier corona informiert
euch mal einfach kommt doch einfach mal
so ich über tag leer und das ist
wirklich das es blanker hohn das blanker
hohn weil das ist eine frechheit und
menschlich echten armutszeugnis meiner
meinung nach all den leuten gegenüber
die in deutschland oder zum beispiel
auch in italien deswegen schon
familienmitglieder oder die nächsten in
ihrem leben verloren haben
es ist eine frechheit bin froh dass die
leute größtenteils kein deutsch können
und diese videos niemals sehen werden
2158 stand gestern in italien jetzt
überlegt doch mal ob du so was runter
spielen willst und sagen wir es ist nur
eine erkältung
es geht wirklich nicht mehr klar
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
was wieder etwas anders sein wird als
die videos die ich sonst normalerweise
mache und zwar leute hat mich mein
bruder max der auch youtuber ist auf ein
video von einem anderen youtuber
aufmerksam gemacht was ich finde so
extrem ist dass wir als youtuber der
über auch in der pflicht sind dazu mal
was zu sagen dazu ein statement
abzugeben ich beziehungsweise ich für
mich selbst als youtuber ich
comdirect.de es geht darum dass die
youtuber lehrern lovelock der unter
anderem für rap interview sandwiches mit
rappern bekannt ist ein video
hochgeladen hat in dem er sehr sehr sehr
krude seltsame verschwörungstheorien als
wahl darstellt und ich finde da muss man
sich schon mal äußern
ich will vorne weg sagen leute pro folge
starten bitte geht die ihn persönlich
nicht an auch wenn die sachen die wir im
laufwerk in diesem video sagt meiner
meinung nach sehr wenig sinn machen ist
es ganz ganz wichtig dass keiner von
euch beleidigt oder über hart angeht
heute gefühle eine inhaltliche
diskussion okay wir leben in deutschland
in der demokratie und in der demokratie
ist ein sogenannter meinungspluralismus
wichtig also dass man viele meinung hat
und jeder kann seine meinung äußern
nur manchmal muss man eben auch sich zu
meinung von anderen äußern wenn die der
eigenen auffassung nach zu weit ab vom
rechten weg sind aber okay ich schon mal
rein es gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
ich bin jetzt eigentlich nicht so der
typ der ganz so oft einfach videos macht
über aktuelle themen oder sich da gerne
mit reinhängt und einfach mit drauf geht
und so aber das was gerade passiert das
wird mir einfach zu viel
okay heute ich werde versuchen dass ich
auf jeden fall den wald von diesem bio
richtig hunger bekommt ich kann wie man
nicht allzu lange ausschnitte aus diesem
video zeigen einfach auch aus
urheberrechtlichen gründen schaut euch
das video gerne selbst noch mal an der
link dazu ist unten in der beschreibung
und werdet euch selbst ein eigenes bild
davon das ganze video von lehrern wird
von seinem titel eigentlich ganz gut
zusammengefasst es ist redet von dem
telefon der korona verschwörung als er
geht davon aus dass hinter dieser
pandemie die wir aktuell erleben auf der
welt eine verschwörung steckt er redet
konsequent in diesem video von die so im
sinne von die da oben ohne einmal auch
nur in eine richtung zu sagen wer das
ist an dieser gerade denkt ja machen wir
weiter
da habt ihr schon gemerkt dass ich
jemand bin einfach skeptisch ist ich
nenne mich ein skeptiker so egal in
welche richtung ich bin auch ein
skeptischer weil diese ganze
verschwörungstheorien aber auch ein
riesen skeptiker von den
mainstream-medien um von dem was die uns
erzählen von der regierung okay da geht
es nämlich schon los also er sagt dass
er ein skeptischer mensch sei was per se
ja eine gute sache ist eine gewisse
skepsis im alltag schadet nicht also
manchmal wollen leute am tatsächlich
unsinn erzählen aber genau da geht's
auch schon los und er fängt an von die
zu reden die die ganze zeit die wollen
dass die wollen dass die wollen dies wer
ist denn die globale verschwörungs gmbh
oder wels und deswegen muss ich hier
einmal ganz kurz was dazu sagen weil das
was gerade passiert das was ich gerade
sie das wird mir zu recht dass süd mit
zu viel und es ist es ist
es ist offensichtlich es ist
offensichtlich was hier gerade passiert
okay okay leute also in gewissen humor
kann ich mir auch bei der reaktion auf
dieses video jetzt hier nicht ganz
verkneifen
also leonov lockt sagt es wird im single
und es ist offensichtlich was hier
gerade passiert und ich vermute der art
und weise nach wie er das ausdrückt ist
es nicht so dass etwa eine globale
pandemie gerade passiert und dass ein
virus um den ganzen planeten kassiert
und wir aufpassen müssen dass unsere
bevölkerung schützen
nein wir liegen alle wir sind alle auf
dem holzweg und aber lehren lovelock
weißt was war es also schon mal rein und
es schwinden mir viel zu viele menschen
auf den zug oder auf dem strom mit es
gibt viel zu wenige leute die mal
reflektiert hinterfragen was da gerade
passiert so es gibt ein paar sprachmemos
herum ein paar stories ein paar berichte
und alle rennen die leben rein kaufen
sich sachen selbst leute wo ich gedacht
habe die sind reflektiert oder die die
haben ahnung oder die verstehen dass da
viel mehr dahinter steckt als um so
einen virus in anführungszeichen
ok also steckt mehr dahinter ist ein
virus
ja also dann wahrscheinlich doch die
globale verschwörungs gmbh an der stelle
wieder mal mit den nächsten versuch die
menschheit unter die kontrolle zu
bringen
danke lena und schon mal für den hinweis
also ich glaube was hier so der fall ist
ist dass du das allgemeine unbehagen war
es sehr viele menschen ja in deutschland
und weltweit haben was ich auch habe von
leon und auch von anderen leuten die so
in die richtung verschwörungstheorie
gehen da hin um interpretiert wird dass
sie sich ja nicht denken ja okay da ist
halt wirklich irgendwie bedroht form von
einem virus sondern es ist eine
verschwörung so von denen die die leute
die
ich muss ich aber aufhören so zu
klingeln die gleich bei mir und was
machen wir alle wir gehen mit drauf wir
propagieren mit denen zusammen
die pflanzen in unseren köpfen irgendwas
ein und wir verbreiten dass wir teilen
das wir reden darüber den ganzen tag wie
können wir leute wie wie können wir da
mitgehen
wie können wir uns an die gesundheitlich
und medizinischen notwendigen
vorschriften halten die unzählige
mediziner weltweit bestätigt haben dass
sie sinnvoll sind wie können wir damit
die leute also sorry ich versuche es
jetzt gerade mal auf eine linie zu
bringen
also das was er sagt ist im kern
wirklich gefährlich ja weil er sagte
aber dass wir sind alle vom system
gesteuert wenn ihr euch an die
quarantäne alte und wenn ihr nicht in
fitnessstudios geht egal da geht es
wirklich um menschenleben
okay hier geht es zum beispiel im leben
von menschen die zu risikogruppen
gehören die über 60 jahre alt sind oder
vorerkrankungen haben
ok es sterben wirklich leute deswegen ja
egal mit wem ich mich unterhalte
spätestens nach fünf minuten kommt das
thema corona virus soundcheck ihr nicht
dass die genau das schaffen was die
schaffen wollen angstmacherei kontrolle
uns vorschreiben was wir zu tun haben
was wir nichts zu tun haben
ja okay es geht weiter mit den genialen
beobachtung
es ist es nicht schockierend leute egal
wo man hingeht alle leute reden über
diesen zu diesem virus ist unglaublich
oder
liegt es eventuell daran dass alle
schulen im land geschlossen haben links
eventuell daran dass die europäischen
außengrenzen dicht gemacht werden dass
öffnungszeiten für fast alle geschäfte
mittlerweile beschränkt sind
nee die nordiren der richtung also die
die die mal machen dass er mit dir links
von mir und es vorschreiben was wir zu
tun haben was wir nichts zu tun haben
freiheit einschränken versteht ihr nicht
was da gerade passiert so gegenfrage
verstehst du warst da passiert also
leute verstehen wir nicht falsch ich bin
ein mensch der sehr freiheitsliebend es
nicht in freiheit ist ein sehr großes
gut aber es gibt gewisse situationen die
man wohl gemerkt auch gut überprüfen
muss in denen es angebracht ist seine
eigene freiheit einzuschränken
solche situationen sind zum beispiel die
aktuelle situation es besteht eine akute
lebensgefahr für viele menschen in
risikogruppen nicht nur in deutschland
sondern weltweit
und jeder mensch der sich nicht an die
hygienevorschriften und die eventuellen
quarantäne oder aufenthalts vorschriften
hält gefährdet menschenleben
das ist ein grund meine freiheit zum
fitnessstudio zu gehen einzuschränken in
meinen augen die wollen genau das und es
ist mir jetzt auch scheißegal länger so
was mit meiner reichweite passiert ihr
könnt gerne dinge wieder mit mir machen
macht ihm gesagt ich bin verrückt ich
habe eine psychose was weiß ich
aber ich würde meine fresse an der
stelle jetzt hier nicht mehr halt so ist
ja auch okay also er kann ja seine
meinung sagen wie gesagt also wir leben
meinungspluralismus viele verschiedene
meinungen sind wichtig für deutschland
sind wichtig für die demokratie
aber gefährlich wird wenn man sich halt
ändert
sich nicht mit dem thema und der
realität auseinander gesetzt hat und
dann irgendwelche kruden theorien die
man sich zusammen gesponnen hat dann auf
einmal raus haut als wahrheit und man so
wie jeder andere youtuber auch
beeinflussbare zuschauer hat die anderes
abkaufen und die dann vielleicht
rumrennen in deutschland sagen ja aber
der lehrer hat gesagt die wir drüben die
flender verschwörung und deswegen halte
ich mich nicht daran keinen kontakt zu
alten menschen zu haben und stecken erst
mal ein paar leute an coole einfach mal
mit menschlichen leben gespielt um die
eigene verschwörungs agenda zu pushen
geht nicht ich bin bereit für meine
freiheit zu sterben so und jeder von uns
muss bereit dafür sein wenn dich auf
dieser welt leben so aktuell also dein
ausführung zufolge sieht eher so aus als
müssten andere für deine freiheit
sterben als müsste eine oma irgendwo in
berlin oder mannheim weiß ich was gesagt
glaube ich den unterricht ist mannheim
dazu müssten erhalten roma in mannheim
vielleicht kennst du dir nicht ist nicht
deine eigene oma von einem kumpel weil
du du glaubst rumtanzt rumschlägt sich
ansteckt sein kumpel seine oma und die
schafft vielleicht nicht also ist halt
wirklich nicht mal es ist nicht mehr
fahren die leute also man kann so was
nicht einfach so raus war meiner meinung
nach wir lassen uns nicht einschränken
es kann nicht sein dass wir uns zu hause
einsperren wegen einem virus denn nicht
tödlich ist ja jetzt nicht gesagt
hat das alles wirklich gerade gesagt
okay alles klar sieben uns mal kurz in
corona großen monitor von der berliner
morgenpost rheinprovinz china 3100 worte
iran 1000 2158 dass ein alter zahlen von
gestern spanien 500 also ich verstehe
nicht wie man wie man dann so was sagen
kann
es gebe wirklich nicht im kopf das kann
nicht sein
das sind kriegst du ständig wegen einem
virus denn nicht tödlich ist normal
euro wie gesagt ich will niemanden
persönlich angehen aber ich weiß
wirklich nicht lehren wo du deine
nachrichten herr bekommst ob du keine
ahnung die sonne anbetete dann sagt dir
die sonne oft wir setzen ein
gefährlicher virus ist oder nicht dran
sagt die sonne halbmayr nähe
du bist bei der weltweit weil die zahlen
die meine informationsquellen ausspucken
sind andere
dieser virus ist nicht tödlich ein
normaler gesunder mensch kann von diesem
virus nicht sterben
hahahaha okay jetzt jetzt wenn wir dann
noch präziser
das heißt also erst nicht tödlich weil
ein normaler gesunder mensch keine wir
uns nicht stören weil ich habe es gerade
eben noch gedacht dass es auf der welt
millionen von menschen gibt die aufgrund
ihres alters ein geschwächtes
immunsystem haben oder die aufgrund von
vorerkrankungen geschwächtes immunsystem
haben aber die gibt es ja schon mal
nicht eine lüge wird von denen da oben
was die da oben haben alte menschen
erfunden und die existieren nicht
möglich es ist fakt es ist bewiesen
hinterfragt man die ganze scheiße was
steckt da dahinter was steckt da was
machen die gerade mit uns was machen die
gerade mit uns ja ich will niemanden
persönlich angehen aber ich fasse mir
wirklich an den kopf wie man sowas
einfach so raus haben kann wo es
objektiv gesehen wirklich um
menschenleben geht also lernen wirklich
möchte ich nicht persönlich angeht wie
kann man so unreflektiert sein dass
einfach so raus zu hauen
sorry ich hab jetzt ein paar stellen aus
dem video raus notiert wir spielen mal
hingucken was hat man sagt da steckt ein
plan dahinter freunde
die wollen uns einschränken die wohnungs
kontrollieren das ist der erste schritt
das ist der erste schritt gucken wie
weit dieses getrieben haben ok alles
klar also leon erkennt mit
messerscharfer auffassungsgabe dass das
der erste schritt ist um irgendwas zu
machen
der erste schritt von irgendeinem planen
wohlgemerkt leon der rap interviews
macht erkennt dass und investigativ
journalisten auf der ganzen welt die
sehr kompetent sind und deren einzige
aufgabe es ist irgendwelche verdeckten
prozesse und
tatsächlich existierende verschwörung
aufzudecken die sind nicht drauf
gekommen
aber lernen der rap interviewer aus
deutschland er hat verstanden wo würde
ich wohl gemerkt keineswegs sagen will
dass ich schlau wenn als er aber ich
würde auch an meiner stelle nicht sagen
ja leute ich habe es aber verstanden
alle anderen auf der welt die haben
recht ich würde sowas nicht von mir
selbst behauptet aber er macht das ja es
gab es schon öfters es gab
schweinegrippe vogelgrippe alle zwei
drei jahre kommt eine neue grippe neuer
währungs der uns anscheinend irgendwie
aus robben soll aber dieses mal dieses
mal sind sie einen schritt weiter
gegangen
si/pro
komm komm schon also ohne wird es ist
halt wirklich so verschwörungstheorie
man lädt irgendwas gibt es dann zu
irgendeinem sie oder die ohne ein wort
darüber zu verlieren wäre das sdk du
weißt doch auch selbst dass du mit dem
was wir gerade sagst viel viel
kontroversen verursachen wirst warum
sagst ja nicht einfach recht dazu werden
wir die sind in deinen augen verliert
eure positivität nicht verliert euren
euren glauben an gott und an mal selber
verliert dem nicht alle gesellschaften
eure familien eure menschen um mich
herum
seit positiv dicker last ruhig nicht von
diesen angstmacherei lasst euch davon
nicht negativ prägen okay ja die stelle
habe ich auch raus
gleich kommt noch ein bisschen heftiger
ist dass das ist ja auch erstmal also
könnte man losgelöst von allem was er
davor gesagt vielleicht sogar ein falls
buch auch als positiv bewerten einfach
auch ungeachtet der umstände ist es ja
nicht verkehrt optimistisch zu sein man
darf man dafür optimistisch sein also
man muss ja auch nicht nur weil jetzt da
eine akute medizinische bedrohung
existiert total in panik verfallen wie
es leider trotzdem manche machen das
stichwort hamsterkäufe sondern kann
einfach weiter sein leben leben und halt
erstmal gut drauf sein so weit hat
aufpassen aber gut aussehen und ich
wette mit dir sterben leute wegen dieser
paranoia
die heute ausgelöst wird deswegen
sterben leute wir sollen keine angst vor
dem virus haben wir sollten angst davor
haben dass die regierung mit uns macht
ist euro aber nee nee also er wird uns
jetzt allen ernstes erzählen dass diese
krankheit diese pandemie die um die welt
geht nicht tödlich ist ja aber was
tödlich ist ist dass leute sich sorgen
machen
also es tut mir wirklich leid aber das
sterben darstellt mir wirklich alle
gehirnzellen ab wenn ich sowas höre eine
virus panini weltweit mit nachgewiesener
maßen aktuell stand heute 17 16 uhr 7500
todesfällen ist nicht tödlich aber dass
leute sich sorgen machen das ist tödlich
naja ok dafür sollten wir angst haben
was passiert hier gerade keiner weiß
genau aber wir machen trotzdem alles was
die uns sagen dicker und wenn die mir
sagen ich muss zu hause denn dann werde
ich rausgehen ich werde rausgehen ich
werde 100 prozent raus gehen so und da
ist nämlich der punkt erreicht wo jetzt
wirklich schluss ist wo ich merke dass
ich ein bisschen aggressiver werde weil
du kannst ja gerne kannst deine meinung
haben kann seine meinung auch teilen
wenn deine meinung gefährlich ist und
andere verhaltensweisen verleitet die
andere wiederum gefährden dann solltest
du das nicht machen
ja aber zu sagen dass du dich nicht an
die medizinische sinnvollen maßnahmen
hält und rausgehen wirst auch wenn aus
medizinischen gründen das rausgehen
nicht sinnvoll ist oder verboten ist
da ist halt wirklich der punkt erreicht
wo du einfach sehenden auges in kauf
nimmt dass deine mitbürger die mit dir
zusammen in diesem land wohnen verletzt
werden oder sterben
nur weil du dich nicht in dem
freiheitsgefühl einschränken will oder
weil du denkst du kannst damit irgend
einer globalen verschwörung eins
auswischen da jetzt wirklich auf ich bin
ein mensch ich hab mich damals dazu
entschieden meinen job zu kündigen alles
hinzuschmeißen damit ich auch meine
eigenen
new york verlegt wird den ganzen ersten
ansagen lustige formulieren
er hat seinen job mit job hingeschmissen
um auf seine eigenen eiern zu stehen du
bist doch bisher ein großer breiter
carlowitz auch locker 95 100 110 kilo
vielleicht und du wirst auch deinen
eiern stehen also ich weiß die leute ich
stelle mir das ziemlich schmerzhaft vor
sowas um eine menschliche freiheit gehen
sobald es darum geht dass ich sehe dass
andere menschen sich bringen dass sie
sich dass diese paranoia bekommen dass
die psychische probleme und psychosen
bekommen 100 prozentig gibt es menschen
die daran sterben werden weil dieser
scheiß psychosen an diesem ein farbiger
einfach nur noch kopfschütteln für sowas
übrigen leute mehr habe ich dafür nicht
übrig wie kann man das machen und wie
kann man wisse was mich wirklich sauer
macht was mich wirklich aufregt leute
ist diese selbstgerechtigkeit mit der
leute die solche verschwörungstheorien
erzählen
ran an den start gehen und so tun als
hätten sie die weisheit mit löffeln
gefressen hatte immer mehr leute zu tun
als hätten sie die weisheit mit löffeln
gefressen vorsicht ja und seltsamerweise
sind auf der seite der verschwörung die
von den bezahlten medizin dann in
deutschland inzwischen sagen ja also wir
wissen noch nicht ganz genau so wir
müssen auch gucken sich das entwickelt
oder das ist jetzt unsere meinung dann
schauen wir mal ja also die kritisch
gegenüber ihre eigenen einstellungen
sind und auf der anderen seite haben wir
die verschwörungstheoretiker und die tun
wirklich so als hätten sie die komplette
welt durchblickt einmal komplett in die
matrix reingeschaut und alles verstanden
der film ich die worte macht euch darauf
gefasst dass wir ausgehen dass wir uns
das nicht mit uns machen lassen so
darauf müsst ihr euch gefasst machen die
für den kampf dicker wer weiß vielleicht
das ist die revolution jetzt vielleicht
es ist endlich dieses ding wo endlich
mal die leute aufstehen werden und sagen
werden wir lassen uns von burschen die
man kontrollieren
es ist wirklich einfach eine meine augen
echt bodenlose anreihung von nicht oder
kaum durchdachten behauptungen es sind
wirklich auch gefährliche behauptung ist
einfach zu sagen so ja wir gehen raus
also gerade eben was auch ich gehe raus
schlimm genug
schlimm genug dass du dir denkst alle
mediziner oder fast alle mediziner auf
der welt sind dumm aber du als rap
interviewer north fence hast die medizin
besser verstanden als die führenden
virologen weltweit okay das ist die eine
sache
schlimm genug aber dann noch immer in
der wir form zu sprechen und so die
zuschauer mit einzuschließen so nach dem
motto ja geht mit mir aus lasst uns ein
paar leute anstecken daher zeit einfach
auf träger das ist wirklich schon fast
massen gefährden so ein video
wenn die wenn die wirklich auch
versuchen uns freigeister einzusperren
digger uns mundtot zu machen
dann können wir das nicht zulassen dass
dürfen und können wir nicht zulassen wir
haben eine verantwortung
jeder von euch hat eine verantwortung es
ist ein gewisses komisches potenzial in
sich muss man sagen also er sagt er ist
ja ich gehe raus mir egal
die da oben ist schon ne ich gehe raus
und dann auf einmal wir gehen raus ja so
im sinne von geht mit raus und dann auf
einmal wir haben eine verantwortung
ja du hast eine verantwortung der gast
eine verantwortung dass du deine
reichweite nicht dafür einsetzt dass
informationen zu verbreiten und
verschwörungstheorien zu verbreiten
macht das meinetwegen im privaten kreis
schlimm genug aber auf der größe mit der
reichweite absolutes no go und das
gefährdet menschenleben und kostet
vielleicht sogar menschen dem ich war
ein riesen skeptiker von
verschwörungstheorien von die regierung
kontrolliert uns wir haben nichts zu
sagen haben ich war ein riesen skeptiker
von dieser ganzen thematik so aber
selbst ich habe es jetzt geschafft
ok alles tat erst jetzt gehofft ja er
hat gedacht leute herz gelegt in dem
atrix gewagt hat jetzt die komplette
welt verstanden wird hat auch medizin
besser verstanden als führende virologen
in monologen was auch immer meinetwegen
leute steckt ihren lauf login irgendeine
in irgendeiner operationssaal der macht
es besser als jeder herzchirurg so er
hat verstanden ist okay gut will top
playern falls du das siehst du hast
dafür hast in deutschland das recht
seine meinung frei zu sagen ich habe das
recht seine meinung zu kommentieren aber
was ist passiert ohne witz wie bist du
an dem punkt angekommen das so über die
welt denkst wie bis dahin gekommen
würde mich echt interessieren vielleicht
vielleicht will man darüber noch mal ein
persönliches gespräch vielleicht auch
eine million im livestream weil ich
dauernd für wenn du wirst verfasst ja
ich habe es verstanden
es geht hier nicht um ein virus oder so
geht es nicht dass meine ehrliche eigene
meinung und die kann ich auf meinem
youtube kanal so teilen wie ich das
möchte ich bin gespannt was ihr dazu
sagen ich erst verstanden hatte erst
verstanden
leon der rap interviewer hat die globale
pandemie lage besser verstanden als
jeder virologe jeder monologe oder jede
andere arzt erst einmal verstanden sehr
gut es sterben menschen an
altersschwäche
weil sie vielleicht noch eine erkältung
dazu bekommen haben oder irgendwie so
und die sagen hier corona hier ist eine
gestorben informiert euch mal einfach
kommt doch einfach mal so ich guck mal
da und das ist wirklich das es blanker
hohn
das blanker hohn das ist eine frechheit
und menschlich echten armutszeugnis in
meiner meinung nach all den leuten
gegenüber die in deutschland oder zum
beispiel auch in italien deswegen schon
ein familienmitglied oder die nächsten
in ihrem leben verloren haben
es ist eine frechheit bin froh dass die
leute größtenteils kein deutsch können
und diese videos niemals sehen werden es
ist wirklich eine frechheit 2158 stand
gestern in italien
okay so jetzt überlegt der nummer aber
so was runter spielen willst und sagen
es ist nur eine erkältung
es geht wirklich nicht mehr klar so
meine meinung dazu hier gibt's ein
weiteres video für euch um ein cabrio
nicht mehr
aus macht's gut
[Musik]